so obviously there are tons and tons of
protons in the Sun the question is if
the Sun were totally made of protons
how many would there be well we can work
that out by taking the total mass of the
Sun 2 times 10 to the 30 kilograms and
dividing by the mass of one proton which
is 1 point 6 7 3 times 10 to the minus
27 kilograms and the answer you'll find
is 1.19 5 times 10 to the power of 57
protons if the Sun were totally made of
protons that is how many would be there
that's really an unthinkable number it's
basically a 1 followed by 50 seven
zeroes a huge number of protons now if
you don't have a calculator handy you
can actually solve this kind of problem
by typing it straight into the Google
search field what you need to do is put
in to e 30 now Google interprets this e
as times 10 to the then divided by 1
point 6 7 3 e - minus 27 so if you type
that straight into the Google search
field you will find it'll give you the
answer 1 point 1 9 5 times 10 to the
power of 57